wir sprechen über den wendler der ist ja
raus rausgeflogen aus seiner villa in
florida die sachen gepackt mit seiner
laura und verschwundene bild aber hat
jetzt eine spur zu ihm zum wendler
wo ist der wendler in seiner traumvilla
in südflorida nein die schicke villa mit
vier schlafzimmern cool inklusive pool
boykott dort mussten er und seine laura
ausziehen weil der mietvertrag nicht
verlängert wurde bild reporterin kate
die pflege hat mit der nachbarin der
wendlers gesprochen sie ist die
schwester des vermieters und über den
auszug der beiden mehr als glücklich es
ist das haus meines bruders erz an ihn
vermietet und er ist einfach gegangen du
weißt nicht warum es gab einfach keinen
grund er ist einfach gegangen vor ablauf
des mietvertrags wir wissen es nicht und
es ist uns auch egal ist irgendwas
passiert wir wissen es nicht eines tages
rief und sehr cool bei an und sagte er
sei weg und wir waren einfach nur
geschockt wo mein gott diese froh dass
er weg ist es war ein alptraum also war
er ein schlechter mieter kein kommentar
[Musik]
aber wo sind die wendlers jetzt erst im
vergangenen jahr verkaufte der wendler
sein haus in cape coral für 890.000
dollar und hatte große pläne statt seine
schulden zu tilgen kaufte ein grundstück
um ein neues haus zu bauen einen
bauantrag gibt es nach bild recherchen
noch nicht die suche geht also weiter
und tatsächlich es gibt eine heiße spur
denn vor ein paar wochen haben sich der
wendler um seine laura auf einer camping
messe wohnmobile angeschaut
reporterin kate die pfleger besucht
mehrere camping verkäufer und
volltreffer der letzte anbieter und
weiter xvi bestätigt die vermutungen
katie wird in einen separaten raum
geführt wir müssen unsere kameras
ausmachen ja ich stehe hier vor der
camping world in florida ganz in der
nähe von dem ehemaligen haus folgen
michael wendler und laura und gerade
eben hat uns der sales manager bestätigt
dass michael laura hier ein wohnmobil
gekauft haben es ist ein ganz
klassisches wohnmobil nicht zu groß die
normale standardgröße mit dusche
schlafmöglichkeiten der preis fängt an
bei 80.000 dollar ab geht aber natürlich
auch bis 130 140 1000 dollar je nachdem
welche innenausstattungen sie gekauft
haben oder welche extras noch dazu
angesichts seiner steuerschulden eine
mehr als stolze summe für das zuhause
auf vier räder
und spott ist ja nichts neues für den
wendler aber jetzt kommt sport auch noch
von denen die sonst selbst verspottet
werden von der deutschen bahn nämlich
schauen sie auf diesen tweet ihr die
bahn hat ganz offiziell das je
getwittert über den wendler den viele
jahre als alu hut bezeichnen ja als
crooner leugner das spottet die bahn
jetzt oben wir haben erfahrung im
transport von aluminium also das hat die
deutsche bahn cargo ganz offiziell für
den wendler übrig so viel spott
[Musik]